si damas et son rôle d'agent secret de
sa majesté en 62 qui a lancé sa carrière
la carrière internationale faisant
qu'ils étaient nombreux à espérer
obtenir ce rôle
oui en fait ian fleming l'auteur de
james bond ne voulait pas de lui
ils préféraient des vies des jeunes et
puis il avait pas ce qu'il fallait un
principe pour le rôle c'est à dire ils
savaient pas ces billets il faut tenir
une cigarette
il venait d'un milieu populaire iv pas
le côté gentleman de l'espion créée par
ian fleming
mais ce qu'ils veulent l'emporter c'est
son charme sa masculinité et le fait
hélas ou heureusement qu'il ne coûtait
pas cher donc on n'était pas trop
certain que ça fonctionne cette histoire
de 0,07 c'était l'acteur le moins
coûteux et il va s'imposer dans le rôle
bien sûr y tient le rôle pour la
première fois dans dr no en 1962 mais il
fera 7 james bang jusqu'en 1983 vous
rendez compte c'est une période de 21
ans ce sera pour lui à la fois une façon
de se propulser dans le milieu du cinéma
il avait déjà commencé à jouer mais
aussi un boulet parce qu'on le ramènera
toujours à ça et tout au long de sa
carrière on entendra sa voix grave on
verra son sourcil particulièrement
expressif et son naturel qui était
d'être effectivement une homme d'action
qu'on a vu dans plusieurs films de
sidney lumet est de jouer cinq fois vécu
et on le vus chez hitchcock
on le retrouvait dans des films où il
était un robin des bois le roi arthur
on le vu porter la bulle parce qu'il
était dans au nom de la rose guillaume
de baskerville un rôle ou jean jacques
annaud a dû l'imposer car on ne voulait
pas de lui
on avait de lui une image assez précise
souvent proches de ce qu'on s'était fait
comme idée ou moment james bang et là
des jeunes voir dans un monastère ça
paraît cette fois sérieux et il l'a
encore il a emporté le morceau
il était très sélectif il tournait pas
n'importe quoi il faut dire qu'à la fin
de sa vie on lui offrait matrix le
seigneur des anneaux plein d'autres
films qu'il refusait il avait fait ce
qu'il avait à faire il avait tourné
effectivement est connu du succès du
début des années 60 au début des années
2000 c'est à dire une période de succès
qui s'étale sur plus de 40 ans
qui est considérable oui 64km reçu de
nombreux prix des longs métrages
comporter dignement ce succès et vous
parler de la fin donc retraite du cinéma
en 2003 après l'échec critique d'un film
s'appelle ali il avait le choix de
continuer ou pas il aimait bien golf et
il s'est installé ici vraiment ce qui
s'est produit
il s'était installé obama je peux dire
que il y avait chez lui une forme de
contradiction il avait des tatouages qui
disait son amour pour les causes
il était considéré comme le meilleur le
plus important écossais vivant par la
population écossaise malgré tout il
avait fui les cosses bien des années
avant qu'on lui consacre qu'on lui
accorde ce titre s'est installé en
espagne ensuite aux bahamas pour
profiter de la vie d'un certain abri
fiscal il faut bien dire il est allé
face aux écossais jusqu'à faire même que
la publicité pour le whisky japonais ce
qui va de la haute trahison
malgré tout il était défenseur aimait
vraiment défenseur forcené de cette
nation de cette identité écossaise et
qu'il traduisait dans son approche du
cinéma le vus dans highlander notamment
où il incarnait ça donc il était cette
présence forte de l'ecosse sur la scène
internationale et d'ailleurs il avait
été anoblie par la reine elizabeth ii un
moment qu'il avait retardé jusqu'en
juillet 2020 et pour l'occasion il avait
revêtu le traditionnel kit qui est oui
le culte et creuset du clan de sa mère
toujours affiché donc son combat pour
l'autonomie de son écosse natale
absolument mais vous voyez donc la
progression parce que c'est un homme de
milieu modeste qui a l'a fait sa vie
sera sur sean connery quelqu'un qui a
fait ses débuts au cinéma
bon d'abord parce qu'il avait un
physique il était culturiste il avait
été joueur de foot et dans les années 50
il a eu à faire un choix
il aurait pu faire une carrière dans le
foot mais on lui ai dit si tu suis le
foot ça dure pas très longtemps alors
que le cinéma se pourrait effectivement
être quelque chose qui te coupent toute
ta vie qui te fasse vivre toute ta vie
et effectivement c'est comme ça qui fera
le choix du cinéma et jour ota qui a
d'abord des petits rôles c'est vraiment
dans l'anonymat
il va commencer ses potes de façon
fulgurante fait des années 50
les choses commencent à se placer pierre
1962 ce cadeau du ciel cadeau empoisonné
d'une certaine façon mais néanmoins le
james bond qu'il incarnera à jamais pour
moi de tous les james bond c'est le
meilleur vous savez d'ailleurs que quand
un nouveau james bond doit être choisie
c'est bientôt le cas on fait passer une
audition qui est une scène de chang
conneries car c'est ça la référence bons
baisers de russie qui était son gisement
préférées on prend une de ces scènes là
et o dia l'acteur c'est ce qu'on avait
fait être daniel craig
bon comment tu le ferais toi et on
compare avec le modèle chante comme lui
alors en fait un grand grand grand
comédien grands acteurs qui nous quitte
effectivement ça nous rappelle plein de
souvenirs et dont ont pu revoir les
films et c'est quand même la chance
qu'ont les acteurs une forme d'éternité
parce que c'est une soixantaine de films
beaucoup de films importants aussi
acteur il marque et merci beaucoup
encore être pas michèle pralong d'abord
une inclusion c'est ta famille tes merci